[Music]
morning all the gentleman next to me
might give you a hint adds to our top
story this morning 90 000 civil service
jobs could be cut as a cost-saving
measure from the government boris
johnson tasking his ministers to look at
plans to act around a fifth of the
workforce with a suggestion the savings
could be used to help ease the cost of
living crisis as you can see we're
joined in the studio by the minister for
brexit opportunities and government
efficiency jacob lee smoke minister
lovely to have you in this morning well
thank you for having me eye-catching
announcement to put it mildly a fifth of
the civil service to go explain just in
practical terms how and when this is
going to happen
well i know it sounds eye-catching but
it's just getting back to the civil
service that we had in 2016 after
francis moore had done the job that i
now do
and bear in mind since then we've taken
on
extra people for specific tasks so
dealing with the aftermath of brexit and
dealing with kovid so there's been a
reason for the increase but now we're
trying to get back to normal um how can
this be done well about up to 38 000
people a year leave the civil service so
the simplest way to do it is to have a
freeze on recruitment which we've done
in the cabinet office but you but you
can't control where those redundancies
come from and that's you're quite right
to mention that because that's a really
important part of this is that we need
to have with the reductions a very
effective learning and development
programme so that civil servants
whose roles may not be the optimal use
of their time can be trained so that
they can fulfill other roles within the
civil service you're the minister
responsible so you will have an idea
already i'm sure
so where exactly will the bulk of these
cuts come which are the most inefficient
government departments well and arms
length bodies because this includes um
the quankos and
what i've seen within the cabinet office
which is where i work and bear in mind
each sector of state will be responsible
for his or her own department um is that
there is duplication within government
so
that you have a communications
department
and then you have within another
department some people doing
communications so it's trying to ensure
that you use the resource that you've
got rather than duplicating it bit by
bit and therefore there are many savings
that come from that and then you have to
ensure that people are being used as
efficiently as possible to do the roles
that are necessary but bear in mind we
took on 91 000 extra actually we took on
more than that um at the peak uh to
implement cavind and brexit
but to be absolutely clear about this i
mean
why isn't this being described as a
return to austerity because that is what
it is isn't it significant cuts to
departmental budgets significant cuts to
deep to departmental staffing levels
it's austerity by another name i don't
think it is because
what is being done is getting back to
the efficiency levels we had in 2016.
that's a perfectly reasonable and
sensible the job's done with
ambition
uh the the administration the
negotiations most of the work in
relation to brexit has been completed
tell that to northern
that's important work but that's not the
same as working out uh how our
laws have evolved and things like that
so the detailed administrative work has
primarily been done but well over half
of all civil servants working job
centres prisoners for hmrc
you're not telling me that they're being
inefficient in those departments either
no no i'm not and so will depend
department by department as to what
roles are needed but there will be
efficiencies that you can get in some
departments through
increased automation increased use of
technology which is something that all
sensible businesses will be doing but as
the institute for government points out
that anyone who suggests that all of
this can come through natural wasted is
wrong there will have to be targeted
redundancies in parts of the civil
service that's not necessarily accurate
um that as i say up to 38 000 people go
every year so you're talking about a
little bit over two years of natural
wastage now you rightly pointed out they
won't all necessarily go in exactly the
area that you want them to go but then
within the pool you've got you will be
able to retrain
people so this is all just ideological
isn't it i mean rather we understand the
conservative desire to see a smaller
state you're certainly not talking as i
understand it you're one of those voices
around the cabinet table disagreeing
with potentially a windfall tax on the
energy companies well the only bit that
is ideological is that we should spend
taxpayers money properly and not
wastefully
now you make quite i mean
you may call that ideologically i think
that's i'm
but do you think that any of your
viewers thinks we should waste taxpayers
money and employ people we don't that's
a deal that's a farcical question it's
not actually because you are saying of
course this is purely ideological when
it's about efficiency it's about doing
things properly it's about governing
effectively and recognizing that every
penny we take in tax has to come off the
backs of people working hard you've been
in power since 2010 if there's
inefficiency in the civil service it's
down to you someone else might have been
waiting the rosette but it was the same
color as that but what i'm saying is
we're getting back to the 2016 levels
which we got to through a major
efficiency and drive but there were good
reasons for taking on extra people yeah
brexit brexit meant brexit cost us money
and then we had to hire
those reasons have passed
but brexit meant that we had to hire
more civil servants the brexit
opportunity
when the expansion when the extra people
were primarily employed 2016. boris
johnson was not the prime minister and
it could have been done very differently
as i say someone else was wearing the
rosette back then i mean
you've been asking people to come back
and work in in whitehall i know that's
something you that has exercised you is
there perhaps the suggestion that those
people who are unwilling to return to
the office could be culled as part of
this 90 000 figure no there is a place
for working from home and there is a
place for hybrid working
but we've seen in the passport office in
dvla dvla had a strike as well which
made things worse the public services to
some people have not been delivered
because of working from home and we've
now had the um fda the telegraph is a
brilliant story saying the fda thinks
people should be able to live abroad and
work for civil service i mean i i didn't
think that i mean the flip side of that
coin is i mean you think that services
are going to be delivered with fewer
people within the civil service yes i do
because we as i've said we've
dealt with some of the issues that led
to the increase in numbers and we can
become
more efficient
i'm not sure if the fda was actually
calling for offshoring i'd be very
surprised if they wanted british jobs to
go overseas it seems rather bold and
unlikely uh call by a left-wing union i
think i think on on that point many will
agree with you um can we talk just just
briefly about what's been going on in
and around dining street can you give us
a running total of exactly how many
fixed penalty notices have now been have
now been handed out but i gently suggest
if you're looking to cut the civil
service you might sack everyone who's
received an fpn but that presumably be
quite embarrassing for the prime
minister
um you'll have to ask the metropolitan
police how many um fixed penalty notes
they've issued that's a matter for that
you could have asked dining street
surely before coming in this morning
well i read in the papers yesterday it
was a hundred but um that's what i've
seen in the newspapers okay but this is
routine reporting for you sure indeed
just just
can we move on to cost of the cost of
living crisis because quite clearly it
is it is a major priority for this
government it would be a major priority
for any government of course in what
ways are you experiencing the cost of
living crisis right now
the cost of living crisis is affecting
my constituents very significantly
personally
i'm not going to talk about me
personally i've asked the question i
know you have and i'm not going to
answer it because my personal
circumstances are very fortunate and i
think my lecturing people on my own
circumstances is not relevant not
helpful
but i do try and help constituents who
get in touch with me and what help can a
member of parliament give to try and
encourage constituents to claim benefits
that they are entitled to to make the
most opportunity to seek the resources
that are there for instance there's a
billion pounds that local authorities
have to distribute to people who are in
particular need and therefore to try and
help my constituents who are struggling
and i'm very well aware through my pace
bag and through surgeries of how
difficult people are finding it i
understand that you're aware of it but
can you genuinely empathize with someone
who is known about let me finish can you
genuinely empathize with someone who is
making a choice about whether or not to
feed themselves or to keep themselves
the reason i ask and you'll you'll
understand this is that people do
sometimes look at you
three-piece suits they're kind of the
affectations the nanny the westminster
townhouse the manor house in the
countryside the personal wealth you know
running perhaps into triple figure
millions that's simply not true
but that is that is the perception and
did they look at you and say how on
earth can this person empathize with me
he's never experienced anything like it
and that's a very fair question but one
of the great strengths of our political
system is that as a constituency mp you
have people come to see you
most weeks to discuss how they are
living their lives and you would have to
be the most stone-hearted person not to
be able to empathize when people come to
talk to you about how they are living
you haven't got the same lived
experience if you genuinely haven't been
clearly because you can't i don't afford
to
again i i asked this because we heard a
little earlier in the week from your
colleague lee anderson saying saying
something in the comments that grabs a
lot of attention wonder we can just play
it to our viewers now
there's not this dude this this massive
use for food banks in this country we've
got generation after generation who
cannot cook properly they can't cook a
meal from scratch they cannot budget the
challenge is there
what did you make of those comments
somebody in my position cannot possibly
say things like that i can't cook myself
and it wouldn't be right for me to
lecture people on how to live their
lives is it right for the youngest
election people what i would like to say
i i want to answer the
long introductory comments that you made
because i think human nature is about
empathizing with people who live
different lives from oneself i think
that's the whole point of humanity
actually is that you understand the
issues the difficulties that people face
without having to do it for yourself
because i've referred to you too as the
as the honorable member for the 18th
century and that's great um but
human nature is understanding other
people's lives but it's also worth
bearing in mind that nobody leads
anybody else's life
and therefore this idea that there is a
category of people who automatically
understand how other people that live
and another set of days it's simply not
true all of which is a really
long-winded way of avoiding answering
the question you know should should lee
anderson have lectured people on not
being able to provide meals for their
children at 30 pounds a day
i would not have said it
fair enough
on the northern ireland protocol
when the prime minister described a deal
as being oven ready to what was he
referring
he was referring to a means of leaving
the european union and that the fact
that the agreement itself
provides for the updating of the
northern ireland protocol
that's in the text that it will be
updated to be made more efficient and
more seamless and that hasn't worked
that hasn't happened the eu has not
delivered that but when he described as
oven ready the deal he was talking about
the withdrawal agreement which included
the protocol and the project included
the mechanism for its updating
what is northern what what is taking
place right now that was not predicted
by businesses on both sides of the irish
sea the updating that was provided for
within the agreement has not happened
properly well that that that wall down
the rcc that border down the irish sea
which we were told would never happen
was generated by a northern ireland
protocol that your government came up
with and your government in fact in fact
you were directly involved in reducing
the amount of time it had for mps to
debate it but bear in mind that there
was um an implementation period
and there was a suspension of elements
of the
protocol and that that allowed time had
there been good faith on the side of the
european union to
provide the update that the agreement
itself expected to take place it just
doesn't strike me as oven ready if you
have to go back to the drawing board
itself i think unfit for human beings i
think you're ignoring the well
now um if we're going to go for sell by
dates everything has an ultimate sell-by
date that's not quite the point the
point is that the agreement itself
provided for its updating and that
updating has not happened because the eu
has not been willing uh to negotiate in
good faith is it illegal is it legal to
change the protocol you know actually as
we're intending to do um we will there
are provisions within the treaty for
unilateral uh changes to the protocol as
we discovered with the eu it was the eu
who invoked article 16 itself in
relation to vaccines um during the
pandemic i wonder if we can just return
to where we started and cuts to the cuts
to the civil service how many advisors
did you arrive with this morning because
it looked like more than two
three four yes they don't work directly
for me they work within the um cabinet
office to work within the cabinet office
and two of my special
do you perhaps detect an opportunity for
some efficiency savings there um i cover
a very wide area of public policy but
there should be efficiency throughout
the civil service
one final question and it's it's on a
topic that i think a lot of people are
are desperately concerned about
afghanistan why did the government not
release the information
that the house of commons had compelled
to do so
well i think the government actually has
provided more information than it's
constitutionally obliged to do
um if you look at the first edition of
ask in may it says that a humble address
falls at a prorogation
now admittedly by the time you get to
the 12th or 13th edition which about 50
years later erskine may says a humble
dress doesn't fall at a prerogation
but by that time humble addresses had
ceased to be part of the house of
commons routine activity why have we not
published the intelligence and the the
intelligence warning about guinea
leverage
fact we know why it hasn't been we know
that has been published because the
security services said perhaps it's not
the brightest of ideas to make the son
of a former kgb spy who who himself was
a media ban you know a member of the
upper house did you look at lord view's
evidence to um the committee that looked
into this yes uh he said that there was
no improper pressure brought to bear on
him that everything was handled in the
normal way
that seemed to be a pretty pretty
convincing answer but genuinely why have
we not had to have not had that evidence
why would we not have that
the government has actually done more
than it was constitutionally obliged to
do just one final point this is just
breaking news i understand that we've
kind of been we are delaying you here
but this would be something that you you
have a view on uh jeffrey donaldson uh
dep leader has said pretty much pretty
clearly his party is not going to be
supporting the election of a new speaker
in storming today
what hope is there for storming right
now
um well i think sir jeffrey's position
has been relatively clear that
he believes the protocol is not
functioning properly and needs reform i
agree with sir jeffrey i think that's a
reasonable position understandable
position of him to take we cannot allow
the functioning of the european union to
undermine the united kingdom
atmosphere smoke we have kept you longer
than we should so thank you very much
for joining us been a great pleasure
thank you uh just a reminder next week k
burley is taking the show on the road
for a series of special programs uh
she'll be going back to her roots
and finding out how the people of wigan
feel about the cost of living pricing
that's going to be here on sky news the
usual time seven o'clock in the morning
from monday
let's have a quick look at the morning's
papers shall we and today we start with
the telegraph the growing round over the
northern ireland protocol leading that
paper exporting the former brexit
minister lord frost is saying that boris
johnson should rip up the deal
with the same toughness he's shown over
ukraine
at the i mean while says the house of
lords is trying to stop the deal from
being scrapped
here's the guardian it says that the us
is so concerned that it's sending a team
of influential congressmen to the uk to
try and intervene
the mail reports that boris johnson has
ordered a massive cut in the civil
service to free up money for tax cuts
with more fines issued over partygate
the mirror says downing street is now
the home of the uk's worst covered
lawbreakers
and the time says former cabinet
minister jeremy hunt has warned mr
johnson that he could lose the next
general election
still to come on the show as the dop's
leader says his party will not support a
new speaker installment when the
assembly sits today i'll be asking
whether a government can be formed when
i'm
joined by the mp for south belfast clear
hana
[Music]
we'll get reaction to the terms of
reference set out for the covert inquiry
the deputy chair of the british medical
association dr david
and just after eight i'll be speaking to
deliver shadow secretary of state for
scotland ian murray
let's turn to the war in ukraine now
where sky news has seen evidence
suggesting
that civilians were targeted by russian
forces as they were fleeing for the
fighting
russian forces have been beaten back in
some areas by a counter-offensive
in eastern ukraine along the outskirts
of kharkiv to be specific
stanley salteef has recently been
liberated civilians are now being taken
to safety after being trapped for months
skies alex rossi reports now
the military guides warns we need to
move fast the road to starry salty is
still dangerously exposed to enemy fire
and even though the russian military is
in retreat here
it is far from safe
all the villages have been battered
but so too have the kremlin's forces
remnants of tanks and armored vehicles
burned up on the side of the road
their bunkers are also smashed and
vehicles they'd used sprayed with
bullets
as we move further into the village what
we see is from another world
spindles of smoke pluming
apocalyptically
into the sky
well the area we're in has been recently
liberated by ukrainian forces
but you can see the situation here is
extremely fluid
this area came under artillery fire
not long ago
and you can see these vehicles which
have been
completely destroyed
by russian forces
what happened to the civilians here is
beyond disturbing
this car packed with toys and baby
clothes as the family tried to escape
and in the midst of all this residents
are still trying to flee
this group only now able to move out
arena widowed by this wall
he was renewable
rescue workers are still dashing through
the shifting front lines
these pictures filmed by the driver show
the danger they face as they try to
reach civilians
[Music]
the advances here are a sign of success
for ukrainian forces
but elsewhere russia continues to make
ground
both sides trading blows in a conflict
which is deepening every day
alex rossi sky news
eastern ukraine
the foreign secretary liz trust is
accused of vladimir putin
of humiliating himself on the world
stage and called for western allies to
do more to support ukraine all of this
at a meeting of g7 foreign ministers in
germany it comes after finland's leaders
came out in favor of joining nato with
sweden also expected to make a decision
in the coming days in an exclusive
interview russia's ambassador to the eu
has told sky news finland and sweden's
nato ambitions
are a threat to the stability of europe
joining nato has never
made any uh country more secure this
will necessitate certain military
technical measures
um
like uh
improving
or raising the
the degree
of
defense preparations along the finnish
border
well let's bring in our europe
correspondent siobhan robbins she's in
helsinki for us this morning good to see
you siobhan i mean just listening to the
russian ambassador to the european union
there i mean his response is pretty much
what we would expect i mean this has
long been russia's position enter nato
and we'll have to have a corresponding
military build up ourselves
yes it's come as no surprise and of
course we heard russia
spokesman from the kremlin yesterday
saying that russia would be looking at
retaliatory moves that this was seen as
a direct threat after finland's prime
minister and president issued their
support for the country looking at
joining nato saying it needed to happen
quickly now the process isn't done by
any means what we're expecting to happen
is a more formal announcement a
suggestion that the application should
happen on sunday and then after that mps
here will vote on it if they support the
application the application would then
have to be ratified by all of the
existing nato members but as you say
it's not just finland it's also sweden
having similar discussions and actually
it's because of vladimir putin's own
actions that this has happened he's
forced their hands with the way that
he's acting in ukraine it's directly
because of that aggression there that
people here have changed their mind
there's been a massive swing in public
opinion here in uh finland for example
before the war around 20 of people
supported joining nato now a poll last
week said it's more than 70 of people so
you can see the impact there but at the
same time other conversations with
european leaders happening about the war
in ukraine as you mentioned the foreign
secretary is in germany for the next few
days at the moment she's at the g7 she's
pushing for allies to continue that
pressure on russia saying that sanctions
mustn't be lifted until russia
completely withdrawals from ukraine
saying that allies have to go further
and faster to support ukraine to give
them weapons and equipment and also
those leaders will be looking at the
strain caused by the war on global food
prices we're all being affected by it
with grain and oil for example being
affected by this ongoing uh crisis so
that's another issue that they're going
to be looking at as well as hosting the
foreign ministers of both ukraine and
moldova of course ukraine currently
being invaded and the moldovan very
concerned that the crisis in ukraine
could bubble over into their own country
siobhan for now thanks very much indeed
uh time to take a look at some of the
day's other headlines and parliament's
intelligence watchdog is now looking
into the appointment of evgeny lebedev
to the house of lords labour has accused
the government of a cover-up for
refusing to release security advice
about the peerage given to the
russian-born businessman
a burial service will take place in east
jerusalem for sharing abu agley later
the journalist who was killed in the
occupied west bank
the 51 year old was covering an israeli
raid in the town of jenin for al jazeera
when she was shot dead a state service
took place in the palestinian city of
ramallah yesterday
a 15 year old girl who's been missing
for more than two weeks has been found
at an address in bristol
maddie thomas was located by police
yesterday lunchtime three men inside the
property have been arrested on suspicion
of child abduction
as many 60 000 nhs staff could be living
with post-traumatic stress as a result
of the pandemic a survey found that nine
and ten workers think it will take them
several years to recover from the
experience
the cancer campaigner and podcast host
deborah james has been honored with a
damehood the forty year old disclosed
earlier this week that she's been moved
to hospice at home care to treat her
terminal bowel cancer
uh let's bring in shaman freeman powell
who's joining us from the newsroom good
to see you this morning shaman tell us a
little bit more about this have we heard
from deborah herself
yes we have she says that she's been
blown away by the honor and it is indeed
an honor usually dame hoods and
knighthoods are offered during the
queen's new year's honors list or her
birthdays on his list but sometimes in
exceptional circumstances some are given
at different points of the year as well
and many would agree that in the case of
deborah james this is an exceptional
circumstance this is a woman that has
been tirelessly campaigning for cancer
research since she was diagnosed in
2016. she used her podcast yumi and the
big c to highlight the plight of living
with cancer not only for her but for the
millions of people that also battle
cancer each day as well and she also
used her social media following to keep
her people into up to date with with the
treatment that she was also receiving
but on monday she did announce that she
was swapping stopping treatment to now
have hospice at home care she also said
that she did not know how long she had
left but she would be spending her final
moments at home with her family and it
was during that announcement that she
also launched the bow babe fund for
cancer research she'd hoped to raise 250
000 pounds but raised almost 4 million
so far already she's done so much and
last night the prime minister confirmed
that the queen would be giving her a
dame hood in a statement he said if ever
an honour was richly deserved this is it
deborah has been an inspiration that the
honesty warmth and courage has been a
source of strength to so many people he
said that through her tireless
campaigning and by so openly sharing her
experience she has not only helped in
our fight against this terrible disease
but she has ensured that countless
others with the big c have not felt
alone now as i say deborah has responded
to this she said she's blown away and
that she'd cried over receiving the
honors and this is a woman with two
young children so hopefully this will
give her and her family some comfort
knowing that all of her campaigning has
been
appreciated shaman thank you
the so-called wagatha christie tron is
continuing at the high court today
uh the court has heard that rebecca
vardy appeared to know that our agent
had leaked information from colleen
rooney's private instagram account to
the sun newspaper mrs vardy was also
questioned about the original post on
colleen rooney's account which led to
the libel case coming to court more than
that of course throughout the day
north korea says that six people have
died and almost 200 000 are in
quarantine following the rapid spread of
a fever across the country over recent
weeks comes a day after officials first
acknowledged covet cases had been
detected there well let's bring in our
asia correspondent tom cheshire who's in
beijing this morning good to see you tom
is there any doubt that this is covert
morning no i don't think there is any
doubt we had that announcement yesterday
they said there was an unspecified
number of cases i think the reason of
the lack of specification is because
north korea by all the evidence we've
seen over the course of the pandemic
doesn't have a very big testing capacity
at all it's only conducted something
like 60 000 tests over the last two and
a half years so when they talk about
more than 350 000 people having
developed fever since late april i think
we can assume that refers to
omicron in particular given the that
rapid rapid spread uh centered around
pyongyang according to kim jong-un who
criticized officials for letting it be a
vulnerable point in the country we have
one confirmed death with kobe six deaths
from that fever but it is a dire
situation for north korea they shut
themselves off from the rest of the
world for two and a half years hoping to
keep kovid at bay omicron has
nonetheless arrived and they haven't had
a vaccination program they refused
vaccines offered by kovacs the vaccine
sharing initiative and when china
offered three million doses of the
chinese vaccines they said give them to
media countries north korea might well
be in serious need now this is a very
very grim situation for the country
because the only tool they have really
is lockdown which is what they're trying
right now but even with lockdown we've
seen in shanghai how stubborn omicron
can be in terms of trying to eliminate
the disease so it is a nervous nervous
point it is an emergency for north korea
that doesn't mean they haven't stopped
doing what north korea likes to do south
korea said that they had fired three
short-range ballistic missiles that
might be to show that even if they're
occupied with a huge health crisis
they're not letting their guard down the
next days weeks months for north korea
are crucial we could be looking at one
of the worst covered catastrophes of the
pandemic so far
tom thank you
time for us to have a very quick look at
the weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well the next few days will bring some
warmth but it won't always be dry and
sunny with some rain in the forecast
it's a mild breezy and mainly fine start
to the day but there is rain over
northwest scotland ireland northern
ireland wales and central and southern
england will stay dry through the
morning
with almost unbroken sunshine by
lunchtime elsewhere there'll be more
clouds especially across northern and
western scotland where there'll be
outbreaks of rain it'll be warmer than
yesterday but still on the cool side in
the northwest it'll stay blustery for
most of us as well
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now for something to seek sink your
teeth into take a look at this
this is the
jubilee pudding it's a lemon and swiss
roll amaretti trifle
i'm just wondering if you can have a
cake for breakfast gemma melvin says
winning the queen's platinum jubilee
competition was a surreal experience the
lemon swiss roll and amaretti trifle was
inspired by her grandparents and her
majesty and beat 5 000 entries to become
the official dessert of the queen's
jubilee celebrations the recipe will be
available online so we can all have a go
at putting it together i right coming up
on sky news breakfast i'll be speaking
to the mp for south belfast as the
leader of the dup says its party will
not support the election of a new
speaker installment
[Music]
welcome back uh as we've been reporting
this morning a meeting of g7 foreign
ministers taking place in germany a
little later liz trust has arrived let's
have a listen to what she's been saying
i'm here at the g7 in germany
it's very important at this time
that we keep up the pressure on vladimir
putin
by supplying more weapons to ukraine
by increasing the sanctions
g7 unity has been vital during this
crisis
to protect freedom and democracy and
will continue to work together to do
just
that the minister for government
efficiency has told the programme that
planned cuts to the civil service are
simply about returning staffing to 2016
levels jacob rees-mogg said the cuts
were not ideological rather that
staffing increased due to brexit and
covered and could now be brought back
down
up to 38 000 people go every year so
you're talking about a little bit over
two years of natural wastage now you
rightly pointed out they won't all
necessarily go in exactly the area that
you want them to go but then within the
pool you've got you will be able to
retrain people so this is all just
ideological isn't it i mean rather we
understand the conservative desire to
see a smaller state you're certainly not
talking as i understand it you're one of
those voices around the cabinet table
disagreeing with potentially a windfall
tax on the energy companies well the
only bit that is ideological is that we
should spend taxpayers money properly
and not wastefully
now you make quite i mean
you may call that ideologically i think
that's i'm suggesting targeting the
public rather than the private sector is
ideal but do you think that any of your
viewers thinks we should waste taxpayers
money and employ people we don't that's
right that's a particle question it's
not actually because you are saying this
is purely ideological when it's about
efficiency it's about doing things
properly it's about governing
effectively and recognizing that every
penny we take in tax has to come off the
backs of people working hard
let's bring in our political
correspondent rob pam who joins us in
the studio i mean rob
before we came on here we were
discussing this you know when when
government brains trusts have run out of
ideas that's when they trot out the old
let's seek out government efficiency the
problem for this government is of course
they're in the middle of a cost of
living crisis and as i understand it you
know it's gonna be a couple of years at
minimum before we receive returns on
this yeah i don't think this is
necessarily an answer to the big
question dog in government at the moment
of what they do to provide more help for
people as energy prices and general
prices rise because
these are plans for the coming years 90
000 civil servants that they want to
get rid of to return it to 2016 levels
now these plans were already in motion
albeit to 45 000 civil servants going
that was confirmed last year so it's
just an expansion of that and i think
there's sometimes a kind of maybe a
misunderstanding of what a civil servant
is i think people think of it as as
someone that works in london lives in
london works on policy and sits around
stroking their chin thinking about big
ideas all day a lot of civil servants
are employed by the department of work
and pensions to work in job centres or
to work
managing probation or to work at the
dvla which we know has had problems
recently and i think what people that
study this and have worked in the civil
service before say is it's going to be
very difficult to get rid of this level
of people
by just targeting efficiencies and
backroom staff at some point you are
going to have to make an impact on
actual frontline services um as well
look we'll have to come back in two or
three years and see where we are on this
there is something to this announcement
that since 2016 numbers have increased
because of brexit and because of covid
so i think there is a general acceptance
that some trimming might be appropriate
but maybe not to this level i think the
final thing i'd say is that jacob
rees-mogg came to his interview this
morning to talk about government
efficiencies with four officials and
advisers of his own now usually top
cabinet ministers only have one or two
he said that was because his policy
brief is very wide i imagine people that
he wants to get rid of in certain
departments might be using a similar
justification uh when he comes knocking
for now rob thanks very much indeed
let's turn our attention to northern
ireland where the newly elected assembly
sits for the first time this morning as
pressure grows over post-brexit trading
arrangements with the eu in the last few
minutes the dup has said it won't
support the election of a new speaker
installment today well here's what the
brexit opportunities minister jacob
rees-mogg told me in reaction to that
just a little earlier
well i think sir jeffrey's position has
been relatively clear that
he believes the protocol is not
functioning properly and needs reform i
agree with sir jeffrey i think that's a
reasonable position understandable
position of him to take we cannot allow
the functioning of the european union to
undermine the united kingdom
i will join now by claire hannah the
sdlp mp for south belfast and of course
a member of the northern ireland affairs
committee lovely to have you on the
program this morning with hannah um can
we start with that which we've just
heard from from uh jeffrey donaldson
this morning the idea that they will not
be involving themselves with the
election of a new speaker in practical
terms what does that mean and and in
kind of ideological terms what does it
say about the dup's desire to to get
installment back up and running again
well in practical terms it means that
the people of northern ireland will be
left without a functioning government
again and that they are being i suppose
held to ransom um
by collapsing an institution and nothing
this dormant assembly does can affect
the outcome
of the protocol negotiations um and
again that frustration is exacerbated
because the protocol is a problem of the
dup and the uk government's
making nobody loves the protocol it's
nobody's
first preference choice for how we
manage brexit but it is in place because
the dep and the uk government voted down
all of the more practical options and
most people including the business
community want to make it work and have
outlined ways and to make it work but in
the mean they want to function in
government they want the cost of living
crisis dealt with they want the health
waiting list dealt with and we know the
damage that stalemate causes because
people here were left without a
government for three years from 2017
when shin fian uh pulled this uh exact
stun so it's another day of frustration
and failure for people here
i keep hearing that the northern ireland
protocol is at the root of the dup's
problems at the moment but but but to
what extent was the protocol actually a
live issue in elections to storm if you
were to listen to shin fein of course
you know became the largest party for
the first time it wasn't an issue in the
doorstep at all
it really wasn't i knocked countless
thousands of doors across uh 14 or 15
different um constituencies and when it
came up it came up in frustration and
that we weren't being allowed
to move on no um it is it does um create
change and and uh for businesses but
brexit unfortunately was a project about
um friction and trade uh barriers but as
i say the business community have
pragmatically um
worked around it to trade is like water
it will uh find the easiest path to flow
and it is doing that we also understand
in the sdlp that um it has symbolic
value for unionism and we regret that
sense of of hurt which is why we spend
five years begging the dup and the uk
government to choose a borderless
solution but uh that that uh that
symbolism can um be addressed and and if
we um if if we follow the logic of the
dup that there could be absolutely um no
differences in trade between britain and
northern ireland then the only outcome
is a hard land border which is not only
um symbolic undemocratic in that the
comfortable majority of people in
northern ireland don't want it it is
also entirely unworkable and would
absolutely demolish um
trade on this island which is where most
of the added value is in our economy
but but when you have as as you yourself
have described it a poisonous political
discourse around the protocol i mean
genuinely what hope that there will be a
functioning assembly any time soon
well
again ultimately we have no choice than
par sharing and partnership and when
people use government as a play thing
which unfortunately the two large
parties do here ultimately they don't
have a better idea than the good friday
agreement and and working together and
respecting different views
and coming back together and i think
ultimately and the anxiety that people
have that direct room would uh would
would take place which is real from from
westminster ultimately um i i suppose
that that will um uh put pressure on the
dup but again the frustration is that
these problems are big but they are
solvable we have solved bigger problems
and the way to um solve the problems in
the protocol is a negotiation between
the uk and the eu and i i reinforce that
point nothing the assembly does uh uh it
can can change the outcome so it is
being held to ransom for no good uh
reason um there are solutions out there
they the eu have um
been flexible and some of the issues on
issues that people didn't think that
they would move on but the uk government
now needs to be flexible as well just
before you came to me i watched um
foreign secretary les trusts uh make a
statement uh about ukraine we are
talking about international law we are
talking about the rules based order we
are talking about governments and world
leaders that can be trusted and at the
moment the uk government is not behaving
uh in a manner that is trustworthy every
day it is threatening to pull the pin um
on an international uh uh agreement that
is the protocol that is there to protect
a sacred international agreement um in
the good friday agreement that is not um
respectable or trustworthy behavior
claire hannah good to have you on the
program this morning thanks for being
with us
the covert 19 inquiry remember that well
it will now examine the impact of the
pandemic on mental health and on
children and young people a consultation
on the draft terms was opened in march
with views sought from the public
professionals and support groups uh one
of those who will have contributed the
british medical association and its
deputy chair dr david wrigley joins us
now dr wrigley great to see you this
morning i hope you're well um so we've
all had a chance to have a quick look at
the terms of reference what do you make
of them
well actually this new information about
the expanded remedies is really welcome
um the they're going to look at the
impact and the role of general practice
which wasn't in there before
the impact on mental health on children
young people and also the collaboration
occurred between health services and the
community and other sectors so it's
really welcome and also there's going to
be a focus on inequalities and that's
something that's really worried the bma
when around 80 percent of those who died
were doctors from ethnic minorities this
needs looking into and we need to see
why that's the case
is there anything not included that you
would wish to have have been
specifically mentioned we know that
burden s hallett of course is saying
that she doesn't want to rule anything
out but that's not quite the same as
ruling something in
i think there are a few other areas that
we would like to see in there and
hopefully that will come into the
reports that are looked at one is around
health and safety law we don't feel that
was looked at enough and whether we need
to look at reviewing that and how it
impacts on workers in the nhs and also
looking and learning from the past now
that we're planning consultations that
occurred in the past exercises and one
was called cygnus that jeremy hunt
actually oversaw uh and that showed that
the country just wasn't ready for a
pandemic and but nothing was done about
that and that's why there were real
problems at the start of the pandemic
with a lack of implementation a lack of
lockdown and a lack of ppe which was a
real major problem for our staff
just in terms of of the the effect that
the covert response has had on you know
people like yourself your colleagues so
there's a study out today showing
60 000 nhs workers could be suffering
from from post-traumatic stress as a
result of of covid 19. i mean does that
does that chime with your personal
experience
absolutely we the bma offers um
counselling services for
all doctors and medical students and
we've seen a massive increase in the
numbers accessing those services doctors
with stress
like symptoms depression anxiety and
that's just exacerbated now with the
huge waiting list we see patients having
to wait longer for appointments and the
whole system is under so much pressure
and that just adds to the workload adds
to the mental anxiety for many
colleagues and that's why we have to try
and tackle this
dr david rigley deputy chair of the
british medical association thank you so
much for joining us really appreciate it
shall we do just do a quick update on uh
the fundraising uh by deborah james um
of course bowel babies she became known
to as i've spoken to her a couple of
times over the years
and she's been in absolute credit
uh we'll just take a look there four
million pounds now over four million
pounds has been raised the original
target 250 000 pounds which is quite
something